à l'occasion de la 8e édition de
l'Europan cyber week de novembre dernier
euh notre ministre Noël Barot a lancé le
dispositif cyber PME qui s'inscrit
pleinement dans le cadre de la stratégie
cybersécurité du plan d'investissement
France 2030 piloté par la Direction
Générale des Entreprises en étroite
collaboration avec la BPI France l'any
et le secrétariat général pour
l'investissement 12,5 millions d'euros
sont alloués à nos PME et ETI pour leur
permettre re de monter en compétence sur
la
cybersécurité ce dispositif offre un
programme complet d'accompagnement àant
diagnostique à la mise en œuvre d'un
plan d'action y compris dans l'achat de
solutions il s'agit d'un véritable
approche à 360°grés qui révie une
importance cruciale pour protéger nos
entreprises des cyberattaques aux
conséquences économiques dramatiques
c'estant les chiffres énoncés au sein de
l'Union européenne près de 30 % des PME
européennes ont déjà été é confronté à
la cybercriminalité au moins une fois au
cours des 12 derniers mois ces
cyberattaques portent une énorme
préjudice à nos économies à notre
compétitivité l'Union européenne a
récemment adopté la directive Nice 2 et
les négociations autour du cyber
solidarity Act sont en cours je salue
l'initiative cyber PME qui complète les
action menées au niveau européen Cees
dispositif initialement prévu pour fin
2022 arrive cependant avec près d'un an
de retard et une enveloppe financière
réduite j'aimerais donc savoir comment
le dispositif sera déployé combien
d'entreprises pourront bénéficier de
cyber PME et si ce dernier sera
reconduit en 2025 pour correspondre aux
plans initiaux
merci